por undécimo día consecutivo las
protestas contra el gobierno de
guillermo lazos siguieron en ecuador los
manifestantes se reunieron en la capital
quito para escuchar el discurso del
líder indígena leónides y show
sino visibilizar los millones de
ecuatorianos que estamos jodidos en el
día a día hemos venido las delegaciones
ay
[Música]
este jueves el gobierno es serio a una
de las condiciones de los manifestantes
y reabrió el acceso a un lugar indígena
de alta importancia la casa de la
cultura para que puedan organizar una
asamblea popular lo que leonidas iza
calificó de triunfo de la lucha este
mensaje del gobierno nacional en aras
del diálogo y de la paz tiene como único
propósito que cesen los cierres de vías
las manifestaciones violentas y los
ataques en distintos lugares de nuestro
país y exige como respuesta la libre
movilidad de personas y de bienes
especialmente alimentos y medicinas sin
embargo un grupo de manifestantes
intentó ingresar en el congreso
convirtiendo el centro de la ciudad en
escenario de intensos enfrentamientos
entre policías y civiles las protestas
se iniciaron el 14 de junio para exigir
que se reduzcan los altos precios de la
gasolina y de los productos esenciales
que han publicado a los sector más
vulnerables de ecuador